de acuerdo a la organización mundial de
la salud
17 millones 500 mil personas murieron en
el 2014 por un infarto
420 millones de personas
sufren diabetes en el mundo
y ahí sub diagnóstico
313 mil personas el año pasado en
colombia
sufrieron un infarto
y estos son cifras son datos son
estadísticas
son números pero detrás de todos esos
números hay historias
hay amigos hay conocidos hay familiares
que hemos perdido
particularmente en el caso de mi familia
el último año ha sido muy fuerte
dos de mis tíos
una hermana mi mamá
guillermo de 74 años murió hace unos 8
meses por un infarto
leonardo hermano de mi papá hace unos
siete meses murió por un infarto
y se hace el más fuerte rubén
de 52 años
quien además de ser de nuestra familia
era el contador en nuestra empresa
y es fuerte y probablemente todos
ustedes tengan personas cercanas que
sufrieron o murieron de un infarto pero
la pregunta fuerte no es si tienen a
nuestras personas
la pregunta fuerte es quiénes son las
860 personas que hoy eran un infarto
están en este auditorio
quienes son las 860 personas que
sufrirán un infarto mañana
y esto nos pone de frente con una
realidad y es que esto es un problema de
verdad esto nos está matando esta es la
principal causa de muerte de acuerdo a
la organización mundial de la salud
seguida por enfermedades respiratorias y
por accidentes cerebrovasculares
el año pasado nada más en colombia
murieron 30.000 personas por infarto
para ponerlo en perspectiva en 60 años
de conflicto que han sido terribles 220
mil personas han perdido la vida
en sólo siete años por infarto el
equivalente a todas las vidas que hemos
perdido en el conflicto las perdemos
y este tipo de discusiones este tipo de
reflexiones han sido muy frecuentes en
mi familia
crecí en una familia en donde las
discusiones de política pública de
desarrollo social
y salud estaban siempre la mesa
mi padre me dedico como muchos de
ustedes paso toda su vida profesional
como profesor de una universidad pública
en mi ciudad natal manizales
y allí formó mucho lo que soy su visión
de la vida centrada en el ser humano y
en la salud no en el dinero
mi madre
marta inés oto
pasó también toda su vida profesional al
frente de una caja de compensación
dedicando toda su energía toda su pasión
al impacto a impactar en la calidad de
vida y el bienestar de muchas personas y
en ese proceso también se formó
desde el mundo empresarial una gran
ejecutiva
y esto me impulsa
a formarme como ingeniero industrial
y así seguimos la carrera y termine
creando dirección junto a mis socios una
compañía en la cual nos dedicamos a
analizar millones de datos trabajamos
con la cps es con las ips es con la
industria farmacéutica procesando
millones de datos para simplificar el
análisis y simplificar la toma de
decisiones aprendiendo del pasado y
logrando predecir infartos o accidentes
cerebrovasculares es hoy en día se
conoce como la inteligencia artificial o
la analítica avanzada
y en ese proceso nosotros terminamos por
comprender
por mi formación centrada en lo social
centrado en el impacto y por lo que he
vivido durante esos siete años junto con
mis socios es que puedo afirmar con
plena convicción la salud si debe ser un
negocio
y esa idea a nosotros nos molesta
probablemente choca con los principios
de muchos ustedes
es una idea que incomoda pero yo me
pregunto porque nos incomoda pensar que
la salud sea un negocio y nos parece
completamente normal que la industria
tabacalera
la industria licores y en muchos casos
la industria alimento genere renta a
partir de la enfermedad
porque nos parece completamente normal
que los grandes estrategas detrás de las
estrategias de marketing de las
tabacaleras sean profesionales que ganen
mucho dinero y socialmente lo aceptemos
pero nos toca la idea de pensar un
profesional de la salud dedicado al
cuidado al bienestar de las demás
personas se enriquezca
y esa idea en mi opinión nos molesta
porque en síntesis el sector salud
hoy también vive de la enfermedad
este es un sector que
ha hecho de la enfermedad un negocio y
desde las aseguradoras lo hemos visto
desde la cps es pensando la enfermedad
la cps se han hecho algo que es muy
cuestionable desde el punto de vista
ético pero también miope desde el punto
de vista de negocio restringir acceso a
medicamentos procedimientos
a un paciente diabético que se le
restrinja el acceso es un paciente que
evoluciona a un paciente renal o con
mucho daño cardiovascular
y desde los hospitales hay un modelo
perverso y hay una perversidad en el
modelo de negocio de los hospitales pago
por evento
si me infarto el hospital factura
y desde la industria farmacéutica ha
existido mucho énfasis los últimos años
en desarrollo de moléculas en la etapa
final de la vida sobre todo en cáncer
donde los tratamientos son muy muy
costosos en la etapa final de la vida y
es cuestionable el resultado de hecho
hay un estudio en inglaterra que salió
reciente y dice que el 40 por ciento de
las nuevas moléculas para cáncer no
tienen ningún impacto no sirven para
nada eso es mercantilizar la esperanza
en mi opinión un paciente en fase
terminal
como cáncer debería estar acompañado con
procedimientos completamente distintos
humanizando ese proceso de muerte
pero la realidad es que
no es sólo responsabilidad de estos
actores incluso nosotros pasamos una
vida alimentándonos mal
es cuidándonos
y creemos que la responsabilidad de
nuestro cuidado está en esas gps en los
hospitales en la industria está allá en
los actores yo lo digo alguna manera un
poco cruda pero creemos que pagando unos
seguros todos los meses estamos bien
pues lo que estamos haciendo es pagando
un hotel 5 estrellas para cuando nos dé
el infarto lo yo sinceramente no
quisiera que me diera
lo que nosotros entendimos finalmente es
que esto no es un problema de buenos y
malos esto es un problema de incentivos
mal alineados
y tengo que decirlo con total claridad
después de siete años en este sector de
prácticamente vivir vivir mi vida de
este sector de estar acá parado gracias
a mi papá ya mi mamá que son parte de
este sector
puedo decir con claridad que los mejores
seres humanos que yo he conocido están
en este sector tienen que enfrentar
discusiones muy difíciles dilemas éticos
muy difíciles tienen que lidiar con
recursos escasos y sobre esos recursos
escasos tomar decisiones que en muchos
casos son debido a muerte
y hay que decirlo también con claridad
gracias al esfuerzo de todos estos
profesionales es que hoy tenemos un
sector que es reconocido como uno de los
mejores en américa latina' y creo
firmemente que tenemos uno de los
mejores sistemas de salud del mundo
tenemos una cobertura universal tenemos
un pago de bolsillo que realmente bajo
tenemos un gran esfuerzo que hoy se ha
cristalizado
pero insisto esto no es un problema de
buenos y malos esto es un problema de
incentivos mal alineados
y lo primero que debemos hacer para
tratar de realinear esos incentivos
enfocados hacia un buen negocio es
redefinir qué es un buen negocio es
redefinir el sentido del éxito
buen negocio no es hacer mucho dinero un
traqueto hace mucho dinero
pero en mi opinión es el peor de los
negocios destruye social y
ambientalmente un buen negocio es ese
negocio que crea valor es ese negocio
que está centrado en el impacto es ese
ese negocio que está centrado en el
desarrollo y por consecuencia genera
muchísimo dinero
y me lo decía hace un tiempo un gran
empresario de la salud a quien admiro y
admiro bastante joseba grajales
y él me decía de forma muy clara y es
juan
se enfoque en este sector a generar
dinero va a perder muchísimo dinero pero
quien se enfoque en este sector de
manera legítima al cuidado al bienestar
y a impactar a la sociedad es quien va a
ser realmente exitoso
el segundo paso que tenemos que dar
para poder hacer
para romper esos esos incentivos
perversos es decirlo con claridad cuando
decimos la salud no debe ser un negocio
estamos aumentando la creatividad
estamos aumentando la innovación estamos
aumentando a miles de emprendedores que
necesitamos en este sector poniendo toda
su energía y creatividad para solucionar
problemas complejos
tenemos que convencernos de verdad de
que la salud tiene que ser un negocio
tenemos que buscar la forma como
sociedad de hacer un gran pacto
y cada vez estoy convencido que esto no
es un problema del sector establece la
prioridad número uno
insisto en siete años han muerto más
personas en colombia que los 60 años de
conflicto sólo por esta patología solo
por infartos
tenemos la necesidad de hacer un gran
pacto
tenemos la necesidad de poner la salud
como la prioridad número uno para
nosotros como sociedad
y entender que quienes están apostando
una alimentación sana quienes están a
post y quienes están apostándole al
deporte todas estas iniciativas que
están buscando impactar en una mejor
condición de vida están en el negocio de
la salud
y tenemos que buscar todos como sociedad
enfocarnos en que la salud sea el mejor
negocio para todos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]